my name is miles kramer i'm a graduate student at
princeton um i work at the intersection of physics
and machine learning i usually apply machine
learning to different problems in astrophysics
and also kind of develop new methods that might
be used for different problems so today i want to
talk to you about this method we've developed
for taking a deep neural network and kind of
converting it into a simple analytic expression
so so this is work with these collaborators
um so let me just start by if you remember nothing
else from this talk i want you to remember uh
these three points so the first is uh symbolic
regression it's it's kind of like it's it's an
underused machine learning model but it's it's
very very interpretable and it's very good at
doing physics problems so symbolic regression is
a machine learning algorithm where you basically
learn to model your data set by searching the
space of analytic expressions so one can convert a
deep neural network into an analytic expression
with the technique i'm going to show you today
and this i think this represents a very
strong way of interpreting a neural
network so i think a lot of traditional
explainable ai techniques they look at
kind of indirect interpretability kind of
seeing what the model's doing but this is
a very strong way of actually converting your
model into a fully interpretable equivalent model
that you can work with so like a simple analytic
expression so the last thing i want to say is that
i think our method also represents a it's a way of
doing symbolic regression on high dimensional data
where symbolic regression would typically be
completely intractable so what is symbolic
regression it is a machine learning algorithm so
you so it's uh we usually do it for regression
problems we want to fit uh the relation between an
input set of features an output set of features so
except the basis so traditionally machine
learning you have some model that depends on
many parameters and you would fit those parameters
symbolic regression you're actually fitting this
space of analytic expressions so uh so you you
search over all the space of analytic expressions
for this function f uh that that models this
relationship so okay if you have this curve so
x-axis is your input y-axis is the output you want
to find a model that could fit this in symbolic
regression what you would do is you would say you
would try basically different functional forms so
you say does cosine fit this no does sine fit this
no uh you keep trying you get to exponential of x
so that's closer and now what you do is you kind
of uh you reward that expression and you would
basically start mutating on that expression and
you would eventually find exponent over x over
two which is the right expression um so so so why
do we want to do this so if you think about it
many many rules in in physics and in natural
sciences in general are kind of accurately
described by simple symbolic expressions so this
is already true so this is some cheat sheet that i
pulled off of google for physics physics 101 and
you can see that so many different expressions
in this cheat sheet are just simple analytic
equations and they are extremely precise at
describing these relationships so i think
i really think the question is like like
why don't we use this basis it's such a good
basis for physics it's so interpretable it's
so concise and easy to compute really why don't
we use this as a basis in machine learning that's
that's what i see the motivation for symbolic
regression so there's this really nice article
by eugene wigner he basically says the miracle of
the appropriateness of the language of mathematics
for the formulation of the laws of physics is a
wonderful gift which we neither understand nor
deserve we should be grateful for it and hope
that it will remain valid in future research
in that it will extend for better for worse
to our pleasure even though perhaps also to
our bafflement to wide branches of learning so in
this article he points out kind of all the weird
connections between different scientific fields
like like pi appears in the formula for a circle
and it also appears in a normal distribution
there's a lot of weird connections in math
and it really seems like these analytic
expressions are just a powerful basis
for describing our universe so okay still
why so concise interpretable you can apply
centuries of mathematical analysis to kind of
detect failures in your model ahead of time and
um and another thing we've we've also seen in
our work is that they may generalize better
to out-of-distribution data than the
neural network they were extracted from
for physical problems and this this might be due
to neural networks with relu activations maybe you
only get like linear extrapolation whereas when
you convert to this analytic basis you might get
kind of better extrapolation properties okay so
so how does symbolic regression actually work
so if i have uh if i have this expression x1 x4
plus cos x2 minus 0.32 i would represent this in
a genetic algorithm package for symbolic reaction
as a binary tree so you can decompose it into a
binary tree so this is so my package piscer this
is how it represents an equation other packages
like cindy you would fit a sparse sum of a basis
set of functional forms and kind of find a sparse
set of coefficients you can also do this genetic
algorithm strategy so in the genetic algorithm
strategy the way it works is you have this binary
tree represent an equation and you apply different
mutation operators from genetic algorithms so
like you take your your multiplication symbol
you mutate it to a division symbol maybe you take
your cosine and you just delete it from the tree
maybe you take your x2 and you mutated to x
or you take your x1 mutated to x2 maybe you
take a constant and like randomly increase it
by twenty percent decrease it by twenty percent
maybe you swap the sign so you have all these
random mutations to um explore expression space
um so i i use regularized evolution in in my
paiser package so in this case you fit um some
small sub sample of a population of equations
and you would find the fittest member of that
subsample so that the equation that best fits
your data and you you mutate it so in this case
you're mutating the you're mutating the constant
and you would basically look for the oldest member
of your population and replace it with your
with this new expression and you just repeat
this thousands and thousands of times and this
is a way of kind of if kind of more efficiently
exploring equation space than just a brute
force search so you would score this and repeat
so so how can i actually do symbolic regression
so there's so if you know like your equation is
going to be a sum of known functional forms
i think cindy is a is a faster approach
it's a really good approach for finding a sparse
set of coefficients in front of a basis set of
functional forms when you when you don't know your
functional basis or you you think it could be like
a very nested nasty expression um i think a good
choice might be piscer which is my package which
uses um genetic algorithms so they both have kind
of areas of of strength um so the way paiser works
is a it's a python package with a julia back
end so if i have this input data set with
with a hundred data points and five features
and say my true equation is like 2 cos x 3
plus x0 squared minus 2 i would put that into
piscer declare what binary operators are allowed
declare what unity operators are allowed i can
also define a custom operator that it can use
and i i let it do this genetic algorithm search
um and in the end so this one is actually really
fast because you don't have that many features
you don't have that many operators um so it can
find this in like 10 minutes um just by kind of
applying genetic algorithms to search the space
okay so so something something really
important with symbolic regression is that
you get so they're compact you get explicit
interpretations they generalize well but they
are terrible at high dimensional problems and this
is because you're dealing with uh combinatorics
you're like if you count the number of possible
equations there's just like a factorial number
like factorial over the number of features so
it blows up very very fast so it's bad at high
dimensional problems whereas say deep learning
is kind of like uh it's precisely complements
this you are efficient at learning in high
dimensional spaces but you are uninterpretable
bad at generalization um and so you can see how
these kind of complement each other so what we
were really interested in is can we combine both
can we take the strengths of both of these and
maybe use deep learning to kind of find a better
symbolic expression so this is what we did so
we uh in our approach you basically train a
neural network to solve your problem because
they're really good at high dimensional problems
you train in your network to model some data set
and you basically want to take that trained
model and try to distill it into a simple
analytic expression so you're basically rather
than fitting the equation on the raw data itself
you're fitting the expressions to the neural
network and then the nice part about this is
uh you can you can train the neural
network with different regularizations
that causes it to be easier for the symbolic
regression to kind of distill so like
the way you actually want to do this
is you structure your neural network
so that it's built up of small internal functions
and each internal function you want to have
operate on a low dimensional space and since
it operates on a low dimensional space that
means that symbolic regression becomes tractable
because now you're in the low dimensional regime
and you can actually run symbolic regression on
the neural network you kind of treat the neural
network as like a the internal functions like
a data data generating process and you try to
approximate it um so as an example like if you if
your internal function in your neural network is
like y equals the sum of g of x i where g is your
learned maybe it's like a multi-layer perceptron
in this example um you would you would regularize
g to be to have a sparse output so you want g to
live in a low dimensional space be like a low
dimensional function and then it's really easy
to kind of you want to kind of rip out g of your
model you like rip it out and then you try to fit
symbolic expressions to it so another example
this is actually this is a this is very similar
to kind of like a graph net you have this this one
multi-layer perceptron that you sum over your data
site so you're summing the encodings of your data
set and then you map that sum in the original node
through a different multi-layer perceptron so in
this example you would want both g and f to live
in low dimensional spaces because then it's it's
easy uh to distill them into a symbolic expression
okay so so another way of saying our method is you
want to you want to design a neural network such
that it has separable internal functions inside
of it so rather than kind of huge latent spaces
you want to have you want to distill smaller
latent spaces and have several internal functions
and when you do this and when you train it with
a sparsity regularization on the latent spaces
then you can try to approximate those
internal functions with symbolic regression
so you approximate those internal functions and
then you compose those symbolic expressions uh
using those using the internal structure so like
if you have some pools inside your network you
would have those sump pools inside the extracted
equation too so you want to compose those symbolic
expressions and in the end you're left with a
symbolic model that is equivalent to your neural
network um so consider like a graph neural network
so this is a single message passing step graph
network you have your function g which is like
maybe a multi-layer perceptron takes the sending
node or sorry that's the receiving node the
sending node is inputs and it outputs some message
you some pull those messages over the receiving
for the receiving node and then you pass that into
a second function which takes that summed message
the current node state and maps it into a new node
state so in this example you would want g to have
a low dimensional input space and output space so
you would kind of regularize that during
training to achieve that goal and then it's
very easy to do symbolic regression on it so
we did this for many different n-body systems
we have like simple particles interacting with
springs or maybe gravitational laws you try to
predict their dynamics with a graph
network and you you encourage this
low dimensional representation and then you
apply symbolic regression to this function g
and you end up with you find the analytic
expression you find is actually equivalent to
the to the true one from your simulation so it's
a way of converting this trained graph network
into an analytic expression it ends up being
the true expression so it's very interpretable
obviously this would generalize very well because
it's literally the true simulator um so i think
it's a nice way of doing things so another way to
look at this is kind of like like a graph network
has a strong analogy to new tony mechanics
so the the latent space of the messages
is kind of like it's kind of like a force so
you're summing over the uh sending nodes it's kind
of like you're summing over interacting particles
and that's kind of like you're computing the net
force so basically uh when we regularize sparsity
in this message domain we're basically like
encouraging it to find the force vector because
that's that's a low dimensional representation
and then your node model might end up being the
acceleration so you would you would approximate
both the edge model the known model and convert
those uh with symbolic regression into an equation
okay so so we tried this for many different uh
data sets so we have like one over r squared one
over r spring law we even have an if statement
describing a force law so this is a really nastykind of interaction law and
So we can actually recover those expressions
So we start by generating these simulations
of maybe particles connected by springs
so these are different simulations recorded
over time and this is the true force law
so we learn to predict these dynamics with a
graph network so you observe and you can see
over time they get closer and closer to the true
dynamics just from the graph network learning this
regression problem now what we also do is we
regularize the internal functions of the graph
network to have small dimensional latent spaces
so you see it kind of pushes this so that it
puts as much information to as few dimensions as
possible so it sparsifies the latent space
so one thing you can do is just
fit the forces to those messages
and it turns out that it's actually those messages
are actually a rotation of the true forces so you
can see it's it's almost a perfect correlation
when you have this rotation so if if this law is
unknown rather than fitting the force you would
apply symbolic regression so you would kind of
fit these messages and you can see you extract
this expression it's the rotated spring law
which is pretty cool so we can we can do this
for many different systems we can recover spring
law one over r squared we can even recover like
nasty discontinuous forces we also did this with
Hamiltonian neural networks so we have thisHamiltonian graph network and we can recover
the interaction Hamiltonian between two particles
the actual analytic expression which is prettycool
So we also, so being an astronomer I am kind
of interested in this technique to to apply it to
astrophysical systems so we have this this dark
matter simulation this very kind of this very
large dark matter simulation over many different
cosmologies and we try to basically predict
the dark matter over density at the center of
a dark matter halo and so we can convert the
graph network into an analytic expression we get
this this cool kind of over density expression
and it turns out it's more accurate than than kind of the the most intuitive expression
you could write down so you can see that kind
of counter-intuitively you're dividing by mass
where you would expect to multiply by mass
so you can actually you can start to kind of
think about how you would theoretically get
this result which is pretty cool and you you
you really can't have that discussion with a
normal neural network you can only really discuss
these kind of these scaling relations when you do
symbolic regression on your graph network so it's
very interpretable in terms of existing physics
you get good generalization which we observed um
it's it's of course accurate it's compact it's a
really nice expression so we did this we tested
this kind of like wignerian prior idea so when
you convert it into an expression even though
it's not the true expression necessarily because
it's like this this dark matter relation you would
not expect this to be a true relationship because
it's kind of just it's kind of just a correlation
but when you actually measure the
generalization to out-of-distribution data
against the graph network it destroys the graph
network like this analytic expression is much
better at generalizing out of distribution
data and i think that's something that's
really interesting as we go forward in
developing machine learning for physics
so restatement you make a neural network
you try to have multiple internal functions
that each work on a low dimensional
space you then approximate that
function with a symbolic equation so you can
use like cindy for if you know your basis
functions piscer if you don't um and then you try
to compose those symbolic expressions together
and that's kind of an equivalent interpretable
model so so one thing some people ask us is why
don't you do straight symbolic regression you have
this you have the sum pool um maybe you can learn
this expression in this expression simultaneously
the the problem with this is that you square
the number of possible equations it's already a
hard problem to do this with symbolic regression
for just just one of these equations but now
you're kind of squaring the number because
you're fitting them simultaneously whereas
with the neural network you can fit z and y
i simultaneously very fast just by a chain rule
so you only get two to the nine two times ten to
the nine possibilities because you fit them
separately um so it's it scales much better
um so uh we we developed this technique last
year we've been applying it to different
um problems in astrophysics so one is like
finding optimal observables for cosmic voids you
can actually extract a analytic expression for the
property of a void which is kind of most uh which
provides the most information for predicting uh
cosmological properties so this is with christina
pablo and niall led this really cool work um
where they they find newton's law from real solar
system data and they also learn the planetary
masses from scratch so we have to kind of give
the masses to the graph network but they actually
can learn the masses which is really cool
so the another application is we're trying
to apply this graph network approach to fluid
dynamics where you basically train the graph
network on some turbulence problem and then you
try to extract the pdes from the graph network so
obviously like these are all expressions from the
same equation um this is a lot more difficult so
we've we've been developed some techniques to get
this working this is with elaine this is also
kind of a really cool application of this idea
so again the takeaways are symbolic regression
machine learning algorithm where you can you can
model your data with analytic expressions so it's
much more interpretable it might provide better
generalization for physics you can always kind
of convert a deep neural network into an analytic
expression with this technique i described and i
think this is a very strong way of interpretation
this also represents a good way of doing symbolic
correction on high dimensional data whereas normal
symbolic regression kind of uh it scales scales
badly um so our code we have a tutorial online
uh piscer this symbolic regression package i used
it's on github as well yeah thanks for listening
i'm interested to see kind of what applications
people do with this technique thank you